في مختبر لورانس ليفربول التابع للحكومه
الامريكيه
تمكن العلماء من تقليد ما يجري في الشمس
وذلك لتحقيق اختراق كبير في استخراج بطاقه
من الاندماج النووي نظيفه ولا تنظم اي كما
يحدث بالشمس المتجدده طاقتها بلا توقف منذ
مليارات السياسيه ووفقا لما ذكر صحيفه
علماء مختبر لورينز ليفربول واخرون من
المختبرات ومراكز علميه اخرى يحاولون منذ
خمسنيات القرن الماضي استخراج طاقه من
الاندماج النووي لكنهم لم يتوصلوا الى حجم
من الطاقه يزيد عن المستخدم في التجارب
سوى الان كما يبدو واعلنت وزيره الطاقه
الامريكيه ان الولايات المتحده حققت
اختراق علميا في مجال الاندماج النووي
وصفته بالعظيم في مجال الطاقه مشيره الى
انه سينههي الاعتماد على الوقود الاحفوري
[موسيقى]
العلماء كافحوا لاثبات ان الاندماج النووي
يمكن ان يطلق تقع اكثر من مستخدمه في
التجارب ويبدو ان الباحثين في مختبر لورنس
ليفربول حققوا اخيرا وبشكل مطلق هذا الهدف
وفي ملخص
تايمز فان الاندماج ادى في الاسبوعين
الماضيين الى زياده صافي طاقه بنسبه 120
بالمئه بالمختبر في عمليه يمكن اعتبار
امتلاك طاقه الغد لانها تنتج القليل من
النفايات ولا ينتج عنها غازات دفئه
الاندماج النووي هي تقنيه تستخدم حاليا في
محطه الطاقه النوويه
الثقيله لاستعاده الطاقه حيث تندمج
وتندريتان خفيفتان لتكوين موافق ثقيله وهي
عمليه يتحرر معها طاقه تكفي لسد احتياجات
كبيره وبحسب تقرير فائنا شلت تايمز فانما
حققه علماء المختبر الامريكي من اختراق
ستكون له اثار كبيره في سعي العالم الى
التخلص من الوقود الاحفوري واذا تاكد هذا
الاختراق فان سنشهد لحظه تاريخيه بحيث
يمكن لفنجان صغير من وقود الهيدروجين
تزويد منزل بما يحتاجه من طاقه لمئات
السنين
[موسيقى]
باحث في معهد الشؤون الاقتصاديه بالمعهد
الخليج الاوروبي للمعلومات اهلا بكم
طيب تقليد الشمس وانتاج الطاقه نظيفه عبر
الاندماج النووي اهميه همم هذا الاختراق
وتحدثنا اكثر عن اليه الاندماج النووي
وليد ان انجلش باللغه الانجليزيه
بين طاقه هو عباره عن طاقه النجوم وهي
كانها تقلد
النجوم والشمس كيف تولد الطاقه
وقد عملنا عليها في محاوله
لاتقان الطاقه وهذه للمره الاولى في
الاسبوع الماضي في كاليفورنيا
تمكنوا من توليد طاقه اكثر مما ادخلت
ايصال درجات الحراره الى درجه عاليه جدا
لتحقيق هذا الدمج
وبالتالي همم
تحقيق هذا التقدم وهو من الطاقه من النجوم
فقط سؤال هل يمكن توظيف الطاقه النظيفه
طاقه لا تنضب في كل بقاع الارض جغرافيا
يعني مثلا انتم تعيشون في لندن نتحدث عن
المملكه المتحده لا يوجد شمس كافيه
لاستغلالها توظيفها والحصول على طاقه
نظيفه وطاقه بديله من خلال الطاقه
الموجوده
ياسن انسناوي
بريطانيا المثلجه في الوقت الراهن نحاول
ان نستفيد من طاقه الهواء ونحاول ان نبني
محطات طاقه
نوويه ولكنها طاقه ثابته وليست مدمجه
وبالتالي
محاوله التعامل مع ال
الركام الذي ينتج
عباره عن مصدر عجيب للطاقه
وتحاول وقد تستغرق الى عشره الى 15 سنه
لاستخدام هذا المصدر للطاقه بشكل تجاري
وبوسع القول ان هذا
المصدر للطاقه لابنائكم قد يكون هذا مصدر
جيد لهم في حياتهن
طيب يعني هذه الاليه توفر طاقه لمئات
ملايين السنين لكن هل هي قابله لتنفيذ
اليوم هل قد تصبح واقع خصوصا في ظل غياب
حول العالم محطات الاندماج النووي
[موسيقى]
الامر هو انها بحاجه الى استثمارات الضخمه
فمثلا في كاليفورنيا حيث حققه هذه النتائج
كانت كلفتها ثلاث مليارات دولار
لبناءها
الحكومه الامريكيه في اداره
عاملات على وضع هذا القانون لتقليل التضخم
ل همم توفير
370 مليار دولار
للانفاق على الطاقه المتجدده
التحدي الكبير هو محاوله
تنفيذ هذه التقنيه الجديده بشكل تجاري
وكذلك فقط بدانا برؤيه
مستثمرين في القصه الخاصه
الا ان المشكله ان الامر قد يستغرق 10 الى
15 عاما لتحقيق
عوائد تجاريه لذلك شاهدنا حكومات في
امريكا وفي اوروبا وهنا في المملكه
المتحده
ينفقون اموال دافعيه الضرائب في هذا الشكل
من الطاقه المتجدده وهي طاقه النجوم
عندما نقرا عنوان خبر فيه كلمه اندماج
نووي تقليد شمس يعني مصطلحات كبيره جدا
علينا كبشر غير مختصين في هذا المجال ان
نفهمها يعني قبل ان ندخل في كل هذه
التفاصيل كان لابد ان نفهم منك يعني كيف
يمكن تقليد الشمس ما معنى ذلك
[موسيقى]
انا اقتصادي
بالتالي محاوله استيعاب
العمليه الدقيقه التي
يولدون فيها فيها هذه الطاقات
وحراره عاليه لتوليد الطاقه واستخدامها
بالكهرباء
تفاصيل العمليه وساعاتكم السر لا اعتقد ان
قطر يستعبون ذلك نحن بين يديك هؤلاء
العلماء والفنيين القله الذين يستوعبون
هذه العمليه وربما الاكثر اثاره واهتماما
انه خلال العامين القادمين وكاله الطاقه
الدوليه باريس
على الطاقه المتجدده الشمسيه والهواء
والنوويه ستكون المصدر الرئيسي لتوليد
الطاقه في انحاء العالم لذلك فان
الطاقه هذه همم ستسهم بشكل كبير ربما خلل
20 سنه
وما سيحدث في ست سنوات القادمه ان الطاقه
المتجدده شمسيه والهواء ستكون اهم مصادر
الطاقه اكثر من النفط وبناء فحم نحن نشكرك
جزيل الشكر من لندن
اقتصاديه وزميل بالمعهد الخليج العربي
للمعلومات شكرا لك